you say say lui c'est bien un nouveau
coup de fil il y a quelques semaines on
a vu ensemble un moyen d'être heureux
c'est l'épicurisme mais les épicuriens
ne sont pas les seuls à vouloir accéder
au bonheur et une autre philosophie
propose de voir les choses d'une autre
manière c'est le stoïcisme
tous ces mecs toute chose je tiens à
vous dire que j'ai dit sénèque mais
j'aurais pu dire epictète ou marc aurèle
qui sont des philosophes qui ont
fortement contribué au stoïcisme
impérial car oui il ya différents types
de stoïcisme mais c'est celui-là qui
m'intéresse sénèque
c'est un philosophe pour romain qui
était entre autres précepteur de néron
un néron c'est un empereur il ya
peut-être brûlé roms c'est pas trop là
et qui a poussé ces mecs au suicide
aaron ce qui est marrant ce que ce n'
est qu' il est mort dans son bain comme
epicure enfin c'est pas vraiment marrant
parce que c'est pas hilarant quoi mais
c'est remarquable quoi france pas
remarquable or ces world mais genre tu
leur marque
ce que je veux dire partout le remarque
c'est qu'en fait c'est pas vraiment bref
sénèque c'était avant tout un stoïcien
et les stoïciens ils ont une vision du
monde complètement différente des êtres
qui rien et d'ailleurs spinoza c'est
grave inspiré de en gros pour eux tous
fait un avec le cosmos le monde est un
tout qui marchent ensemble et il ya une
âme du monde avec laquelle notre âme
comme unique est en fait c'est comme un
être unique ou un grand animal duquel on
fait tous partie
ça fait chier d'être l'année future
montrer du coup une conséquence de cette
vision c'est qu'il ya un déterminisme et
on va aller plus loin qu'avec spinoza
puisque là on va même parler de destin
donc si un dessin cercle ya plein de
choses qui vont nous arriver qui ne
dépendent pas de nous et ça c'est super
important
c'est là que réside la clé du bonheur
pour les stoïciens le social va prendre
une grande distance par rapport à ce qui
lui arrive il ya les événements qui sont
extérieurs à toi qui ne dépendent pas
que toi et il y as qui est propre à tout
comme la nature
tu as raison etc mais les événements ne
t'a teigne pas directement
il ya une barrière entre les deux et
cette barrière c'est le jugement et le
jugement c'est le tien et il dépend de
toi et c'est ce qui se passe dans ce
film de ouf qu'est gladiateurs où le
héros maximus et ben il est général tout
va bien il devient esclave
tout va bien il devient gladiateurs on
essaie de le tuer sa famille se fait
carbonisés tout va bien le mec se plaint
jamais en fait je passe ta remarque est
pas envie
ce point jamais et en fait parce qu'il
comprend que le divin agit comme un
metteur en scène et qu'il faut jouer du
mieux possible le rôle qui va te donner
au kef tap coppet à c'était génial
maxime est juste on a peur du changement
tu vas devenir esclave avec l'éditeur et
or à violetta forment plusieurs fois
appelé les enfants et tous ok non
maintenant
non non tu gassmann toujours le smile ya
c'est ce que je veux ok lights c'est bon
green screen que les ai tout de suite
ok ok ok maxime stone meilleur pas y
passer quand coco ce qu'il faut
comprendre c'est que c'est pas les
choses quitte affecte c'est ce que tu
penses des choses par exemple si je
perds un être cher
bah c'est pas la perte en soi qu'il
aurait affecté la perte en soit c'est un
fait c'est ces lignes de texte dans un
journal voilà c'est comment je vais
vivre cette perte qui va m'affecter
c'est l'importance que je vais lui
donner qui va m'affecter d'ailleurs
concernant la perte d'un être cher
les stoïciens se prennent la tête que ça
comme le montre et puis peut-être dans
le manuel ne dit jamais à propos de rien
que tu l'a perdu dix jeux les rangs du
ton enfant est mort tu l'a rendue avant
le stoïcien qui font pas semblant
maman quand est-ce qu'on rend mamie du
coup le stoïcien pour être heureux il va
adapter son désir et ne désirait que des
choses qui dépendent de lui par exemple
ça n'a pas de sens pour un stoïcien de
dire j'espère qu'il fera beau demain
ces genres anti stoïcien donc ça demande
une réelle maîtrise qu'on va acquérir
avec l'exercice qu'on appelait la cesse
et c'est ça qui va te permettre
d'arriver à la pâte et ya l'absence de
passion alors plus un petit mot sur les
passions les passions c'est pas genre
l'équitation ou la photo voilà ces jeux
les gens m'avaient parlé dans les bars
d'info du coup de fil 9 et du coup de
fil disent en gros les passions c'est ce
qui va perturber affecté ton âme la
pâtée ya c'est donc un état ou rien at
affectés rien ne va être perturbée tout
c'est comme de l'eau quoi tout glisse
sur toi voilà voilà ça c'est stoïcien
bon alors par contre c'est difficile
d'être stoïciens et d'avoir la classe
autre différence majeure avec les
épicuriens c'est que stoïciens lui il va
refuser d'aller chercher le plaisir en
fait pour lui plaisir et souffrance
c'est les deux côtés d'une même question
non je te dis mon gâteau escient c'est
une pierre
[Applaudissements]
voilà j'espère que le stoïcisme et
maintenant plus clair prendre aux
intrigues à garder en tête que c'est une
philosophie qui a vachement influence et
spinoza nietzsche le christianisme aussi
par exemple et que c'est une philosophie
qui est pas si différente de
l'épicurisme que ça je postais sur ma
page facebook un tableau qui est
récapitulatif entre les deux
philosophies que j'ai trouvé et qui est
vraiment pas mal si cette vidéo vous a
plu n'hésitez pas à partager ou à vous
abonner si ce n'est pas déjà fait et moi
je t'envoie du love et de la piste
[Musique]